[Music]
mama's boy news whoo syllabi good MA
better fat Bosco
I remember a 98 year-old moved into a
nursing home to look after her 80 year
old son what that's crazy
so the mom is healthier than the son
yeah wait what the age difference 18
years there's a teen mom oh good night
that's like you looking after Isaac when
Isaac's 80 yeah okay so if you took care
of yourself better than Isaac did and
then you were 98 and he was 80 and he is
right us but you're still like hella
lively I'd be like that huh kind of yeah
that's amazing so Tom is the son and ADA
is the mother and so he Tom went into
this nursing home about a year ago cuz
he needed more care but ADA has been
taking care of him his entire life Wow
and then finally a year after like he
moved in she ended up moving into the
same nursing home so she could be closer
to him she could help take care of Tom
along with like the nursing staff how
come she's been taking care of it his
whole life does he have any you just
never got married he was there like
attached oh wow so music mama's boy
failure to line I see yeah it's so cute
cuz she was like yeah I say goodnight to
Tom in his room every night I'll go and
say good morning to him I'll tell him
when I'm coming you're a sick [ __ ]
freak I was simply saying that a 90 year
old woman coming downstairs is very
difficult
looks like Jill's the one that clicks on
the incest porn I knew it's a popular
category I just didn't know who has
changed dramatically you know I think my
mind went there because I think it's
such a weird [ __ ] relationship that
like the the son and the mom are so
attached and I'm like well what's the
next thing you might as well just
[ __ ] have a sex with each other cuz
it's so [ __ ] weird in my head but
you're a hater that's love like that
where it's attached to the hip where
it's like he'll look crazy like that I
could see you would take a beam like
that oh I don't know it's a totally
crazy look there's a new board what are
you talking about I want to try the
teaching a man now
you're like quit [ __ ] cry-baby [ __ ]
hey little [ __ ] I think I got cute
again I think I think it's cute when
it's a baby and a mom and then once you
go into like you're 20 years old yeah oh
it's like you're 80 yes then it's like
not so cute but then once you're 80 now
and your mom's I got a hundred years
she's able to take Carrie it's cute
again I think it's all the way cute
because I hope that Isaac still asks me
to pick him up when he's 25
no that's creepy cuz like the way she
paints it too because she's like when I
go to the hairdresser he'll look for me
to see when I'm coming back when I when
I get back he'll come to me with his
arms outstretched to give me a big hug
like it just seems so loving they're
like best friends - super does he have
down syndrom no just a more straight
aways have any things wait wait wait so
then I'm confused because if it's why
why why do you guys think that like why
was that mine they're just wondering if
he's disabled so that's the reason why
his mom had to be around him all the
time like always taking care of it like
he's mature if his maturity you know
like is not that hey with mom's [ __ ]
every night yeah I what that question is
because in my mind this fairy tale mom
son best friend type of relationship is
so rare right it's really rare so I'm
thinking okay what are some other
possibilities that are gonna cause this
and I asked that first and then when she
says there's nothing then I'm like okay
cool didn't let me accept this fairytale
relationship that's the tone yeah yeah I
just pictured a really cute down
syndrome adult that's awesome they look
like the same age early teen years apart
in child
she's had three other daughters so it's
Tom and three sisters are they still
around the daughters or well one of them
passed away when she was young but the
other Tula probably on like 70 I think
she was like 14 no she was 13 she only
lived till 13 so this family can be like
four or five generations right she's
like 9090 see some 198 guys he's like 80
and then the next one could be like 60
and then the next one could be like 40
and in the next one can be like 20 and
then the next one can be like maybe I
want to be a really quick six
generations alive to be like the old the
cool guys like when your grandkids come
in you're just good morning [ __ ] you
know your employee no like you're you
did that obscure grandpa that just still
keeps the lingo that he used I think he
gets along with his grandkids like that
and his grandkids I think he's such a
jerk I'll be following as a [ __ ] but
you know at the age soon you're not
gonna give a [ __ ] though so what's your
definition of the cool grandpa huh could
tell stories about me
oh okay you know you and your grandpa
yeah like with my grandpa where he
treats me like a piece of [ __ ] and I
love him to death for it I want to be
the grandpa that's like that does own
grandpa like things like you dress at
the young people store and then like
young people she's cool she blazes and
she chills with kids and stuff you know
she goes to raise you know what's really
dope when you see those like 70 year old
dudes that looks like his swabiz [ __ ]
they look [ __ ] hole yeah like they
dress dope still they still got that
chiseled jawline and [ __ ] you know I'm
saying so it makes you wonder what the
[ __ ] they look like what they were
younger
bubbly some some people look way hotter
when they're older hmm they're like wine
there's a Betty wait I think she's way
too cute AHA but she's like cuter than
what she would her younger there's this
dude like this Taiwanese dude that's
like 50 years old but he looks like he's
like 25 years old [ __ ] yeah he's like
Jack still in Asians man yeah I think
he's like a personal trainer
oh yeah but the guy just threw me off
their like married oh so you guys how
old do you think this guy is outside 26
27 she'll he's 50 holy moly yeah
but he talks about like the upkeep that
it takes like takes care of your skin
you gets like regular like your laser
shed whatever whatnot but do you get
tougher no that probably would kill him
I don't want to look young though I want
to look old like that too like I want to
look like a [ __ ] kung fu master
fossil when your grandpa yeah like I
want to look ancient like I want to look
like those old old ancient like people
that travel alone you just want to look
like air you also want to like feel like
it to like your body's old no I just
want to look like it so I can start
dressing like it because I think you're
in your mind you're probably picturing
just your hair yeah and maybe you're
picturing just the body that you have
you know no I'm wearing like a robe
well what about the body though like oh
no like a kung fu master scoliosis able
body
no like you know like PI me yeah like
you see you want to be able to do the
whole yeah I want to do that I want to
look like a stereotypical ancient Asian
character because like in the movies of
Last Samurai or whatever like I can wear
those things and look real like I could
walk around in a [ __ ] armor I could
walk around and look at like a Chinese
emperor I want to look the part
you know and if by the time we're all
didn't like the status of old people
then don't aren't associated with
wardrobe like that would you still want
to be like that is where we were still
like wearing like [ __ ] obey and and
the hundred Oh like that becomes the Oh
people oh I don't know man I just want
to look like them I don't know man I
just don't want to get old not right now
what's all to you I don't think like age
means all to me it's like habits like
I'm already having old people [ __ ]
habits like the other day we were at
Smorgasburg right and we're just
listening everybody talk we're talking
about fiber and pooping I was like
that's all people talk like why are we
talking about this right now but it was
so fascinating this is true if you don't
have enough fiber you can't poop oh [ __ ]
I used to make fun of people who talk
like this yeah yeah and then I'll talk
about that playing basketball like do
you feel all done do you feel like
you're an old person or if I you just
talk old [ __ ] no I just talk all [ __ ]
because but there is stuff though that
you can't bet well this is probably
because I'm not a shape too but you know
when you're on the basketball court and
even
matter how big I was back I could do
whatever I wanted yeah but then like you
see these like 18 year olds Baker run
like back-to-back games like [ __ ]
seven or eight or ten of them it doesn't
[ __ ] matter I had to take a break
after our half of a half-court game but
you haven't played either though I don't
think that has anything to do it a no
but my spirit usually could keep me
going I think Bart did a good job of
breaking that [ __ ] down for you though
Bart's doing some good Asian parenting
and giving you negative reinforcement so
you just traumatized and while you're
playing basketball you see Bart going
I don't mind made you are getting older
I just don't like the feeling of it yeah
like I don't mind looking at the mirror
and having hella linkle's and [ __ ] that
doesn't [ __ ] matter I still want to
keep my youth fire that's what I want to
have another kid like doing this Martin
racing I'm like I feel like I could have
ran up that hill like nothing but
seniors did the Spartan Race and that's
the point I couldn't even fathom doing
it and you can get it back if you train
more you'll get the fire ya know but
then the other thing too is like now I
feel my age because like my joints just
it's not your age girl there's 50 60
year olds doing the race and getting top
ten I know and also you're really
[ __ ] young waiting about your joints
yes it almost sounds like it's cuz I'm
so heavy you know like my joints are
just hurting it's like no you're just a
hundred pounds you're just young I'm
just talking about the youth fire like
the feeling is a little different it's
that youth motivation where everything's
new and fresh exactly everything is like
what's this bro gonna be like yeah do
you go to Vegas for a hundredth time
it's like you know what it is after you
go to certain place it's like that right
yeah that I can't wait to go hang out
with my friends go how's that yeah even
though her joints are rickety but you
just got that fire cause like I'm kind
of losing it though I'm slowly I feel
myself want to see the wall more no not
the world part it's more like the like
I'm excited to go do this thing like I
don't feel that anymore she's done a
million times you've been a grown up for
a while now
yeah I felt like the first time I
encountered like my age was I was taking
a picture of the fan and they're like
okay c-can you do the dad with me I was
like what's the dab and this is like a
couple years ago oh is that our meet and
greet yeah what's a dad and they're like
hey I'm like is that like from the
Naruto or something it sounds like it's
that some ninja [ __ ] like what is that
and yeah I was like yeah and immediately
from his face I was like okay I'm
embarrassing myself and I'm [ __ ] what
[ __ ] now like that's it I'm done I'm not
hip that's how you just got you gotta
say yes and you'll see what they do
oh yeah first let me see how you your I
just don't do it it let's dab it out I
think like one of the things to like
that is true it doesn't show your age
but that's why now you just be like no
just to save yourself you know that sure
like no it's like it's not your baby yo
can you like milliwatt with this no it's
like why you think you're too cool just
don't look stupid when I do it you know
but they don't know that they just think
I'm being an [ __ ] and I'd rather take
that then being on yes
what's the milliwatt
[Music]